8:30, Hurricane update.
Our powers are flickering.
So we got the kids ready, put them in bed,
got a bedtime playlist. The wind is whooping. We have what is called.
Yeah, like,
the impact windows, and so normally you can't hear, like,
rain or anything, and we can return here.
So it's intensifying.
Trying to get the kids to sleep before we lose power,
before the worst of it. And honestly,
I think I'm gonna do a melatonin
and try to sleep through the whole storm,
man. Just freaking out a little bit.
Yeah, she has PTSD from Ian.
We took a direct hit from Ian two years ago,
and she is old enough to remember that part of it,
and so, yeah,
remember is fine. Yeah,
he only remembers parts that we told him about.
So she's freaking out a little bit.
So we're all gonna go to sleep and hopefully wake up and it's over.